vié montrond analyste politique et
fondateur du centre d'analysé politique
au stratégique straten bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur hercules
ans à leur entretien téléphonique hier
entre angela merkel et vladimir poutine
pourquoi tenez tel temps à s'entretenir
avec le président russe
je pense que et l'allemagne sont le
principal interlocuteur pour la russie
aujourd'hui non seulement en europe mais
également le redire dans le monde
occidental
pourquoi parce que moscou a compris que
paris était totalement dans l'alignement
avec washington et que washington essayé
tant bien que mal de pousser ses pions à
la fois en ukraine mais essentiellement
dans la perspective d' essayer
désespérément d'empêcher l'achèvement de
la construction du gazoduc nord stream 2
alors moscou dénonce des provocations
dans l'est de l'ukraine kiev s'inquiète
des mouvements du côté à des troupes
russes que se passe-t-il concrètement
alors il ya différentes choses qui se
passent la première chose et ça c'est
une volonté de l'ukraine depuis les
accords de minsk un don qui ont été
signés en février 2015 et bien le cren
veut en sortir
pourquoi parce que ces accords
l'obligent à négocier directement avec
les républiques de d'honnête et de
google donc mes républiques dites
séparatistes et dans le cadre de ces
accords et des négociations la russie
n'est pas partie prenante
elle est le garant tel est observatrice
à égalité avec l'eau et c'est eux et
même s'ils ne sont pas signataires du
document avec l'allemagne et la france
qui sont censés être les garants du côté
de kiev justement de l'application de
ces accords
ces accords en plus d'avoir donc été
signé par le prédécesseur du président
il inscrit le président part au chan qu
ont été confirmées par une résolution du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu c'est à
dire qu'en principe pour kiev comme pour
washington il est impossible d'en sortir
mais depuis le début kiev a considéré
que cette que la signature des accords
de minsk
était ce qu'ils appellent la solution
croate la solution croate c'est à dire
que en 92-93 pendant les guerres des
lieux austalie la croatie a perdu la
guerre contre la serbie
elle a signé un accord de paix et
pendant deux ans elle s'est réarmé avec
le soutien de washington et de et de
berlin est finalement lancé une
offensive qui a provoqué l'épuration
ethnique en fait des territoires qui
étaient contestées et qui était occupé
par des cernes et le rêve officiel c'est
des gens comme l'ours en cause par
l'enquêté à proche conseiller de deux
présidents prochaine co le rêve de kiev
ça a été de faire la même opération
le problème c'est que poutine n'est pas
mis le c beach et que les républiques
populaires de donetsk plus grandes sont
à la frontière russe et ne sont pas
complètement isolé et que moscou se
tient fermement sur les accords de minsk
et que officiellement ni paris ni berlin
ne peuvent les remettre en cause ni même
washington tout simplement parce que
encore une fois il y à une résolution du
conseil de sécurité
donc ce qu'espère kiev c'est que en
bombardant les populations civiles du
côté des républiques autoproclamées cela
provoque une réaction disproportionnée
de côté de donetsk de lougansk et qu'
ils prennent prétexte de cette réaction
pour lancer une offensive et sortir des
accords de minsk et pourquoi pas réussir
cette guerre éclair donc qui les fait
rêver alors bon je suis très sceptique
sur les capacités de l'ukraine à le
faire d'autant plus que depuis le mois
de mai 2019 la russie distribuer les
passeports russes aux citoyens des
républiques autoproclamées qui le
désirent
et aujourd'hui on en est à plus de 400
milles et c'est ce qu'a rappelé hier
d'ailleurs le représentant de
l'administration présidentielle russe
monsieur dmitri kozak en disant que si
jamais les pieds vient en fait
s'attaquait aux citoyens russes et en 4e
à quatre cent mille à louga riscal de
l'est hé bien la russie interviendrait
évidemment que la russie que l'ukraine
n'a aucune chance face à voir mieux et
comment appréciez-vous d'ailleurs le
fait que le président ukrainien se
soient rendus sur la ligne de front
si vous voulez mais il ya deux choses
l'essentiel je crois que c'est pour la
politique intérieure le président des
dden ce qui est extrêmement contestée
aujourd'hui les partis qui ont le plus
de succès ce sont les partis qui sont
contre lui et surtout des partis pro
russe vous avez d'un côté l'ukraine
l'alliance pour pour la vie je crois
donc qu'il est dirigé par monsieur
medley tchouk qui est alors qu'il est
citoyen ukrainien est sous sanction du
gouvernement écrit parce que les laits
le gouvernement ukrainien vannes vient
d'inventer les sanctions contre ses
propres citoyens en dehors de tout cadre
juridique et vous avez un deuxième
partie également qui monte en puissance
et qui est et qui est très populaire
notamment chez les jeunes qui est le
parti de du blogueur anatolie charrie
donc il s'appelle justement là ça arrive
c'est un jeu de mots c'est là c'est la
bulle rouge et c'est parti là sont très
populaires sur les réseaux sociaux sur
youtube puisque toutes les chaînes
d'opposition en ukraine ont été censurés
de manière arbitraire par le président
céline ce qui est donc en fait céline ce
qui est c'est comme son prédécesseur
petro porochenko de jouer la carte du
militarisme puisque dans la mesure il a
il a trahi ses promesses électorales de
réconciliation à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine
il s'est rabattu sur les sur les parties
les plus radicales de des factions les
plus radicales du pays qui sont
minoritaires mais qui tienne je dirais
la violence le pouvoir par la violence
sur le l'ukraine et surtout un
alignement complet sur la politique
américaine
et puisque désormais bien dubaï donne
est de retour et john lui-même à une
pression à l'inter puisqu'il ya des gens
qui veulent on parle même pas de
revanche sur la russe idée de vengeance
beaucoup de l'opinion publique autour de
joe biden était persuadé que le night
round 4 avaié pour la russie est
aujourd'hui s'aperçoit que finalement
ils ne peuvent rien faire de plus que ce
qu'a fait donald trump notamment sur
leur stream 2 mai sur le cren donc à
beaucoup d'agitation
oui je vais malheureusement devoir vous
coupez en tout cas merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions vous aviez morose
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique et directeur de strates paul
mercier vaud